a quick daily cancellation today we're
going to cancel jill felipe
a noted feminist who being a feminist
commits in cancelable infractions every
day but this one actually has
little to do with feminism here's what
she tweeted um i know the thing parents
hate most is when non-parents assert
what they will do as parents
which is inevitably smug and incorrect
but i am 100 sure i will never ascend to
a kid's menu
or the concept of kid food and then she
continues everyone who is like oh this
is so unrealistic just wait until you're
a parent
do you think children in most of the
world order off of the kids menu and
survive primarily off of chicken fingers
and plain pasta
that's what she said now i'm not
interested in spending much time
discussing the merits of the children's
menu i can only tell you that as a
parent the four children ages seven and
younger
not only do i not avoid places with
children's menus but i won't take my
family there
unless they have a children's menu in
fact what i'm really looking for is a
restaurant with a children's menu
that gives out crayons before the you
know for the kids to use before the food
comes out
and that's that is loud and obnoxious
and filled with whiny
crying kids throwing chicken nuggets all
over the place squirting ketchup on the
walls
i want a restaurant that is just a
nightmare of loud noises and
questionable smells
for me as a parent that's going to be
the least stressful
least anxiety-inducing environment
because it means
i don't have to worry about my own kids
being loud and obnoxious
i know they'll fit right in the worst
thing imaginable is when you go to a
restaurant with a bunch of kids
and you walk in and it's quiet and
there's a bunch of older people without
children eating
and they have like fancy cloth napkins
at the table and the entrees have names
you can't pronounce and there's no
children's menu and they don't sell corn
dogs or boneless chicken wings
that's when you know you're in for a
stressful dining experience
those are one of the most stressful
moments as a parent of young kids every
noise your child makes will reverberate
through the establishment and if say
your seven-year-old son
makes a fart noise which causes your
three-year-old son to laugh hysterically
and make his own fart noises
um the older couple at the table to your
right will
look and shake their heads with horror
as if this is the first time they've
ever been in the vicinity of young boys
and this is what you have to deal with
so as a parent that's what you're trying
to avoid at all costs
no give me loud dirty cheap
unhealthy that's what i want in my
dining establishments if i have kids
with me
because that's where i know i'm home but
that's all a side issue really the real
point is that we have here the classic
faux pas that even jill herself
acknowledges you know she she not
acknowledges what she's getting herself
into
this is a non-parent making a confident
declaration about what she will
do or not do when she's a parent all
non-parents do this
all current parents did do this before
they were parents
and we all regret having done it we all
look back
on our past selves when we said things
like when i'm a parent my kids will
never eat sugary cereal or
when i'm a parent my kids will never
watch tv or when i'm a parent my kids
will never walk through the grocery
store and bare feet because they lost
their third pair of shoes this week and
i was so fed up with it that i said fine
you're just going to walk around without
shoes all day if that's what you want
and we think back to that and we laugh
at ourselves and we wish that we could
reach back
through time and space and grab
ourselves by the shoulders and shake
ourselves and say stop talking you fool
you know not what you say but we can't
so we are stuck with what we said doomed
forever to carry the yoke of our past
ignorance
let me give you an example for my for my
my own life
i can remember as a non-parent when i
used to drive in my car
and driving in my car as a non-parent
like everything else
was easy and carefree i could listen to
music i could
maybe listen to an audio book i could
roll down the windows and enjoy the
breeze it was quiet it was tranquil
just me and the open road and i remember
sometimes my tranquility would be
interrupted
when i would end up behind a minivan in
traffic and i would notice that it had a
tv
and the tv was playing cartoons or a
disney movie or something
and then i would always shake my head
and say ah what a shame tv in the car
the car is a time for quiet reflection
or fruitful conversation not tv
those parrots are clearly inferior to
the parent that i will be when i am a
parent
yes when i'm a parent i shall never let
my kids watch tv in the car
it will never happen and then i had kids
at first i stuck with my previous
pronouncement uh mainly because i didn't
have a tv
in our car at the time so it was sort of
easy but after a few years we purchased
a chevy suburban that has a tv that
drops down from the ceiling
and i remember saying to my wife upon
purchasing the vehicle
as i tried desperately to remain
obedient to the pointless rule i had set
for myself
i said to my wife we are not going to
use this thing
i forbid it and i stuck to my words on
that
valiantly for about three hours
but you know the thing about kids in the
car is that they're a lot like kids
outside the car
except now you're stuck in a metal box
with them as you careen down the road at
high speeds
there isn't going to be any quiet
reflection and if there's any
conversation in that environment it will
be fruitful
only in spurts but most of the
conversation will revolve around
philosophical questions like are we
there yet can i have a snack
i need to pee luke called me a poopy
head other similar topics
all coming at you relentlessly for hours
on end
unless you put on the tv and like magic
it all stops
and you realize now that that
you're the one in the car rather than
being the judgmental pretentious
know-nothing and the quiet peaceful
sedan behind you
and you realize that there actually
isn't any particularly good reason not
to turn the tv on other than out of some
weird sense of principle but it's a
principle grounded more
in the need you felt as a non-parent to
believe
that your hypothetical parenting skills
were superior to the actual parenting
skills of actual parents
so you turn on the tv and you enjoy the
silence
at least as much as you can because now
instead of listening to the kids fight
you have to listen to scooby-doo
it's a trade-off not a perfect one but
you'll take it
there are a lot of trade-offs like that
in parenting but that's a
simply a reality that you that you you
can't fully appreciate or realize until
you have kids
until you're down there in the trenches
with them
every single day of your life so what i
would recommend if you're not a parent
just
seriously take it from me never say
anything about what you will or won't do
when you have kids nothing i don't care
how obvious you think it is
because you never know just don't say
one damn word and then you could go into
into parenting when you finally have
kids
without dealing with the judgmental gaze
of your own past self
that's my tip and uh so yeah jill
philoppevic is is cancelled and and
all non-parents who say stuff like this
are cancelled so which means i'm
canceled you know we're okay everyone's
canceled
it's another one of those we're all
cancelled hey you
uh yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated